zum konservieren genau was die
welternährung betrifft geht es bei den
nutzpflanzen um die wurst den globalen
agrarmarkt den saatgutmarkt dem
dominieren gerade mal eine handvoll
multis doch letztes jahr 2017 da regte
sich kreativer widerstand da wuchs eine
kleine aber feine open source tomate
open source eine tomate für alle
[Musik]
wir verehren sie verzehren sie auch im
winter
dabei ist beim liebesapfel bordeauxrot
fast nichts mehr gold was glänzt
geschmack oft gleich null
anbau
handel preis menschen und pflanzen
unwürdig
ein produkt der monopolisierung
[Musik]
deshalb kam diese cocktailtomaten
letztes jahr auf den markt mit einer
open-source-lizenz open source heißt sie
ist für jeden zugänglich jeder kann sie
nutzen kann sie vermehren kann sie
weiterentwickeln und kann sie auch
weiter geben
das einzige was man nicht darf ist sie
mit eigentumsrechten zu belegen mit
sortenschutz und mit patent saatgut das
allen gehört johanns coaches idee
revolutionär denn landläufig ist kein
saatgut vor patenten sicher bayer und
monsanto wohl bald fusioniert daudi
punkt sind denn da nur wenige konzerne
kontrollieren mehr als die hälfte des
weltmarktes und so die genetischen
ressourcen heike sagt dieser
dokumentarfilm wie ernähren sich mitte
des jahrhunderts die prognostizierten
zehn milliarden menschen
der regisseur ist überzeugt nicht in dem
sich bauern auf das ertragreiche hybrid
saatgut der multi verlassen und abhängig
werden
denn dieses kann und darf nicht weiter
gezüchtet muss jährlich neu gekauft
werden heike sagt auch johannes kotschy
in ihm wuchs der gedanke
wütend macht mich dass wir
jahrzehntelang demonstriert haben aber
das ist nichts passiert ich habe mein
ganzes leben in der entwicklungshilfe
zugebracht mit der beratung von
kleinbauern und habe einfach gesehen wie
essenziell die saatgut frage ist als da
sind ernährungssicherung anpassung an
klima wandel und ökologisierung der
landwirtschaft freies saatgut und
vielfalt
dafür kämpft auch eva gelinsky seit
jahren sie ist mitarbeiterin der
stiftung prospecierara mit hauptsitz in
den medien gärten basel für den einfluss
der maltese sei auch die politik
verantwortlich
sie versucht natürlich eben für die
großen kapitalistischen organisierten
unternehmen die entsprechenden
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen ja das hat
aber ein patentsystem gemerkt und jetzt
bei diesen fusionen merkt man es auch
werden keine wirklichen hürden den
großen in den weg gelegt ja umso
wichtiger dass die samen bibliothek von
prospecierara saatgut von alten gemüse
und getreidesorten am leben erhält
auch beim roten gold mit der
vereinheitlichung des saatgutes geht
nämlich wissen verloren
das überlebensnotwendige wissen wie man
eigenes saatgut züchtet setzt erntet
denn der druck ist enorm die bauern
machen ist auch mit weil der handel ja
auch entsprechende ansprüche stellt also
gerade bei gemüse zum beispiel möchte
eben einheitliche qualität er möchte
große chancen auf einmal geliefert haben
die das gemüse muss lagerfähig sein es
muss transportfähig sein und diese
sorten kommen dann eben von den größeren
unternehmen
doch gerade eine sorte die heute nicht
mehr gehandelt wird könnte in 20 30
jahren wichtig werden wenn extreme wie
trockenheit überschwemmungen oder stürme
ausgelöst durch den klimawandel über uns
hereinbrechen
da brauchen die genetische vielfalt und
wenn wir jetzt sehr einheitliche sorten
haben dann ist die gefahr dass es einen
totalen ertragsverlust gibt sehr groß
weil jede pflanze gleich reagiert so wie
jede gleich aussieht und gleich schmeckt
makellose einheit und eintönigkeit
herrscht in unseren verkaufsregalen
doch haben wir uns das nicht selbst zu
verdanken
ja es braucht ein umdenken beim
konsumenten und das ist schon auch nicht
einfach denn ich meine wer denkt wenn er
in den supermarkt geht an saatgut wenn
er an nahrungsmittel kauft aber im
grunde hängt die frage der nachhaltigen
ernährung beim saatgut an saatgut ist
kulturgut die basis unseres essens
verzehren in ihrem doch vielleicht
sollten wir einen samen in unsere köpfe
pflanzen
[Musik]
song viva die cocktail tomate mit open
source lizenz sie ist ein kleiner
schritt aber ein wichtiges signal für
die zukunft
[Musik]
sie verwenden auch richtiges fleisch für
ihre würste etwa von